rioting continued in minneapolis last
night as looters anarchists and other
assorted scumbags took advantage
of the implicit permission they've been
given to steal and destroy at will we
know this is the way it works now if
there's a
police shooting well only a police
shooting of a black person of course as
we discussed yesterday police shooting
of a white person
we're not supposed to care about that
but police police shooting of a black
person what that means is that you're
allowed to just go out and destroy
things that's that's the precedent we've
set now
one store that got hit especially hard
was a dollar tree
in downtown minneapolis the store was
ransacked
vandalized and then set on fire
now let's watch some brief footage of
the aftermath
and even more importantly i want you to
listen to this clip let's listen
[Music]
all right uh you hear that it sounds
like
people laughing and joking around after
they just randomly destroyed a local
business for no reason
the media tells us that the people who
did this are emotionally distraught
angry striving in their own unique way
for racial justice
from the look and sound of it it seems
to me that these people just thought
it'd be kind of fun to steal and burn
some stuff
that's it now all kinds of jokes could
be made here about the whole idea
of looting a dollar tree of all places i
mean a store that already practically
gives its items away for free
and you loot there but there really
isn't anything funny about it the fact
is that low-income people in that city
rely
on the dollar tree in places like dollar
tree for household goods and groceries
the quote protesters decided to speak
out against police brutality by once
again
victimizing members of their own
community
and and they are protesters again of
course just just so we know after a
brief detour on january 6 2021
we're back now to calling rioters
protesters and using euphemisms like
unrest to describe the mass destruction
of property so make sure to update your
language guides accordingly meanwhile
the police on monday afternoon before
the second round of rioting kicked off
released the body cam footage of the
attempted arrest
and then shooting of dante wright
initial reports were that wright was
pulled over for having an
air freshener in his car this was
immediately translated through the
demented translation engine known as
twitter into dante wright having been
shot by police
for having an air freshener as expected
none of this is anywhere within the
vicinity of the ballpark of the truth
not true at all right was stopped for an
expired registration
not an unusual thing to be stopped for i
myself have been stopped for the same
reason
on more than one occasion mostly because
i have a deep phobia of
sitting in the dmv and i'll put it off
for as long as possible basically until
they
pull me over and give me a fine that's
when i know that it's time to do it
in wright's case the cops upon stopping
him
found out that there was a warrant for
his arrest he was wanted on a weapons
charge and had skipped his court
date wright had a rap sheet extending
beyond even that including an arrest for
aggravated robbery a few months prior
the brooklyn center police chief said
that wright
was shot accidentally after he resisted
arrest
and climb back into his car to try and
escape one of the arresting officers a
female
pulled her gun when she meant to go for
her taser
now the body cam footage seems to fully
support the claim
that it was accidental let's um and this
is disturbing obviously
so i'll give you that warning but let's
watch it now
oh
okay so the main reason i want to play
that because if you're listening to the
audio you couldn't see what happened
there but uh he
they were resting right and he and he
broke free tried to get into his car
um but it's what you hear her say at the
end it's obvious from her reaction
that she didn't mean to shoot him you
know now that's no excuse of course
and it wouldn't get her out of and and i
suspect it will not get her out of the
criminal charges that
are probably coming any officer that
can't tell the difference between a
taser and a gun shouldn't be on the
force
that's uncontroversial i think we all
agree nearly everyone's on the same page
on that score
and there is i would guess near
universal agreement that she should not
have made the mistake she made
everyone agrees she'll now be held
accountable for that mistake
if we were interested in making actually
useful reforms to the police however
what we talk about now is how a female
police officer
who obviously can't physically subdue
suspects and also isn't competent with
her service weapon
managed to remain on the force for we're
told now 26 years
there's quite a lot of talk about police
reform but this is reform
the reform we really need and it it's
it's the one that we don't talk about
it is a hazard to have cops on the force
who can be easily overpowered by almost
any male suspect that they come across
and that's going to put them in a
position either where suspects get away
or they have to resort to a taser or a
gun where more where a more physically
well-matched police officer may not have
needed to use either
but again the police reformers on the
left they don't want to have that
conversation
i mean a female police officer is 26
years old on a force um
this now is a middle-aged woman she's
not going to be physically subduing
anyone and obviously not competent with
her with her service weapon
26 years she made it
but like i said we don't want to talk
about that even less do we want to talk
about and have the conversation about
dante wright's behavior
now i realize that by saying what i'm
about to say i put myself in line for
all kinds of angry accusations that i'm
a heartless victim-blaming sob and so
forth
but the truth is that i actually don't
want people to die
talk about an uncontroversial view what
should be uncontroversial
i don't want people to die i don't want
people to be shot by the cops
i don't want cops to end up in the
position that this female officer is now
in
i don't want any of this it's all bad
everything about this
is bad i don't want any of it and anyone
who feels this way who actually wants to
preserve human life
along with peace and law and order while
we're at it would acknowledge
the following reality which is this
if dante wright had not resisted arrest
he would be alive today period
he was wanted on a valid warrant okay
this wasn't some ticky tack
thing this this was not him getting shot
in the process of
a traffic stop no he was found in
possession of a firearm
that's what the warrant was about that
according to minnesota's minnesota state
law he was too young to possess
also he has a history of drug and
robbery arrests which would probably
make him ineligible for a permit i
imagine
what this all means is that he broke the
law and the police have a right and
responsibility to bring him in
they were doing so peacefully without a
problem okay
until wright pushed the officer away and
tried to speed away in his car planning
i suppose
to lead the officers on a high speed
chase with a passenger in the vehicle
with him
this was a very bad plan it is a plan
with literally
no possible positive outcome
if you're wanted on a warrant and then
you run from the cops
absolute best case scenario is that you
end up getting apprehended a little bit
later
and now you have a whole slew of new
charges on top of the original one
you buy yourself maybe a few minutes of
extra freedom in exchange you get a few
years
extra in prison so
best case scenario when you do what
dante wright did there
is you go to prison for longer that's
best case
worst case is what happened to dante
wright
there is no plausible scenario
where right runs away and actually
evades the police successfully
and then lives happily ever after that's
not going to happen
it's either prison or the hospital or
the morgue
moment that dante wright pushed the
police officers away
and got back in his car he made a
decision
that was absolutely guaranteed to lead
to the hospital the prison or the morgue
no other possible options the only
outcomes
when you do what right did which means
that if we want young men like right to
avoid prisons and avoid the hospitals
and avoid the morgues and i do
that our message should be don't do that
am i saying that wright is partially
responsible for his own death
yes of course he is he made a choice a
bad choice any legal choice
that set off a series of events which
resulted in his death
does that absolve the police officer no
you know
two people can be responsible for an
event that happens that
that is quite often the case so she is
also responsible
there's lots of responsibility to go
around but when you absolve
rights and people like right when you
absolve him completely
all you're doing is encouraging more
dante rights
which means more death and more
suffering
and more mother's morning you are not
the compassionate one in that case
you may get to play the compassionate
one on the internet or out in the
streets when you're protesting quote
unquote
but in truth you are a callous and a
moral person because you don't really
care
you would rather stand on dante wright's
grave and posture
than actually do and say things that
might discourage the next young man
for making the same self-destructive
choice
but we're all expected to play this game
right the media tells us that dante
wright was shot during a traffic stop as
if there is no difference at all between
a man who gets shot in the head executed
simply for going 12 miles over the limit
like he's speeding the cops walk over
and just shoot him dead
and say that's what you get for speeding
you know they want to they want us to to
pretend that there's no difference
between that
and a wanted fugitive who pushes the
police away and tries to speed off in
his car
when they're arresting him we're
supposed to see the latter scenario as
identical to the former when we know
that they are not
identical this is just another
common sense insight that many people
are hectored into pretending that they
don't see or understand
and as we refuse either due to cowardice
or ideological commitments or whatever
else
to acknowledge the very clear role that
the george floyd's and dante rights of
the world play in their own demises
more and more suffer that same demise
their lives don't actually matter to the
people who do most of the screaming
about how their lives matter
they're just props chess pieces to be
moved around on the board
while we all ignore the simple truths
that are staring us right in the face
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content